hi I'm Charlize Theron and I'm Seth
Rogen and we're gonna answer questions
for families yeah yeah while playing the
puppies oh no a goat obviously because I
was raised in South Africa on a farm we
had a ton of animals but my first pet
was a baby goat named book which
translates from Afrikaans to English as
goat your goats name was boat yes I had
a hamster named Aloysius and it has a
sad ending the story well it's obviously
died eventually but what's sad is I gave
my hamster a birthday like totally
arbitrarily I think your birthday is
like June 5th and then it died on its
birthday oh it is like a Twilight Zone
episode my dogs are both rescues I've
always rescued dogs they're the best
dogs they're part of my social media I
wore them out to sell my movies your
dogs yeah
cuz I can't do that with my kids so I do
it with my heart yeah I dress them up
and they love it oh my god oh my god my
B yeah I think these dogs actually
really suit my nan Shirley's is
personality type of me
you have a beautiful giant majestic dog
and I was a shivering little shell of a
dog
[Laughter]
[Music]
her she's named after the video game her
full name is the Legend of Zelda Miller
Rogan which is a mouthful so it's
shortened to just elder when you meet my
dog she looks like a zone it's like a
very fitting name for my dog this dog's
name should be Sheldon I haven't because
I haven't had 70 hours to kill lately
[Music]
probably so much I would I use to say
any Hall but can I still I don't know
where do we stand on that
[Laughter]
[Music]
not very often
we're very professional oh you get a
great invite Ostrow it gets tense when
people start to break if actually
something funny is happening I find
because like nothing's a bigger bummer
than filming something funny and then
not being able to use it because you
started laughing I'm gonna put this
whole dog in my mouth oh the way by
Warren this was pretty it was a pretty
good wig ya know I loved the wig I wore
and Snow White and the Huntsman cuz it
was ridiculously long and it was like
cut from a 12 year old virgin that hair
was like it was like no human hair it's
not human
[Music]
young adult come adult to all the old
adults she goes on a cruise with Patton
Oswald I would see that I could have
made sequels to my films and I've said
no the that her mom was in jail what was
her name okay what are their mom's was
in jail yeah
Demi that's it Demi Demi needs this
season of some sorts of something for
sure oh I'm realizing that I have still
to impart a lot of wisdom on them
they're just not understanding a lot of
they're not part of you know you know
yesterday we were talking about Medusa
and I said do you know where Medusa's
from and my oldest went yeah New Jersey
I have a lot of work wrong from anywhere
other than ancient Greek mythology it's
New Jersey Florida I don't think I'm
allowed to talk I think I did I've never
been in a Disney movie before but they
sent me talking points and I think they
said don't talk about that but actually
but but I mean I'm Pumbaa she's Noah so
they do share seats I could say that
yeah it's gonna bite my dog he's gonna
bite my nose okay that's my hair so
hurry yeah I've incorporated by petting
these puffs provided by Pacific puffs
rescue they need a home for more
information go to Pacific Pop's rescue
calm yes
no I know tell the people out there
[Music]